You've left a big scar in your past,
right?
As long as that scar is heavy enough to escape one wing, everyone
will continue to walk that path. That's
interesting.
I don't know if you'll show me how to erase my wounds Do you want to erase my wounds?  The
one wing that was pierced
will spell out a guidepost to you Just
now I was a little surprised
[music] The
sound of a strange cat Writing something beyond what I should say
It's the same as the sound
[music]
Iwa-
san, what's wrong Shiroyama Polka
What do you
know about Iwanome?  Yeah,
don't forget it anymore But don't
erase this mark and show it to others
This mark is a guidepost that we must follow and at the
same time it is also a one-way ticket that invites death So
why did I write this
I just showed the way
Heart
[music]